when people say you know they say after
seeing a broadway show how can these
people be doing this 700 times
[Music]
thank you so much for being with me on
20 minute leaders i'm so happy to have
you here
thank you so much i'm really excited
when did we
do mamma mia together that was
seven
that was nine years ago okay so mamma
mia then we did legally blonde
we did you can't take it with you you've
done a dozen
other productions but those those are
the ones that we did together
and i had the time of my life under your
command as the director
and and i'm so happy to have you here
because i'd love to spend the next 19
minutes or so
talking about theater talking about
education and
what how does this all fit in and what
is it what is it like being a drama
teacher
and educating you know all ages k to 12.
so
talk to me a little bit about what do
you do
okay so uh i i'll start
from the beginning i mean i'm i'm going
to start next year will be my 10th year
at uh
america in israel i'll be celebrating a
decade which feels
like uh it flew by you know um
and it started with me teaching the
middle school and the high school
uh teaching them drama and directing a
play
for school uh a year so i had one play
in the middle school one in the high
school
mamma mia legally my first that was my
first play that was my first musical and
it's just uh i look back and it's just
fantastic
as in we were rock stars we were not
hit we were a hit and it was amazing
and i think that it's uh set a tone
for what theater is expected and it
should be like
at our school ever since and i i mean
i do my best to bring it out there every
every single year and usually we do but
it's just like
it's just it was such an amazing
experience yeah right next to your head
over here i'm gonna put now a small
thing from amam and of course
i'm gonna put pepper and tanya dancing
um and then as the years passed
i started teaching in the kindergarten
and then i added preschool and then i
i started working with the elementary
school as well and it ends up that i'm
teaching
from preschool three-year-olds up to uh
18 year olds
what is teaching drama how do you teach
drama
what does that mean okay so i think that
you know if
you don't i okay i'll start from like i
i studied acting okay so i went to
acting school and
i uh learned to be a professional actor
and um but it's not drama is not acting
so what you do when you become
a drama teacher is try to teach
drama as a language okay it's a means of
communication
and that's my motto and that's the first
thing any class will hear from me the
very very
start of a course and say to them you
know we're not going to become
the next meryl streep in our class we're
going to be
uh learning a language in which we can
express ourselves
in a different way a way to communicate
with one another
a platform in which we can express our
feelings emotions
in a way that is um artistic
and creative and i think that that is
you know these are the main focuses that
i think about when teaching drama
and it's a means of communication and
it's creative it's a creative outlet
in an era of technology in an era
of uh screens
because you know when i went to ais i
had half of my classes i had my laptop
open
in some classes i was a rebel if i had
my laptop open
because because because you know some
teachers still wanted us to have
notebook i don't think
teachers anymore are have that have that
dilemma i think that
it's pretty much a lost battle by now
but i think that i was very fortunate to
be in a transition age where
i experienced both the physical learning
in-group
experiences communication in class and
not just one-on-one with computers
now i believe every first grader almost
uh has a computer that they're working
with
and then they come to liran's drama
class and the computers are aside
why why is this important to have this
outlet of human human communication for
you
so i think that one of the most
important so first of all they're not
allowed to bring a computer to my class
it's the first thing that i tell them
like you are not
i don't want you to use a computer what
would they use it for
uh they would use well first of all you
know there are drama teachers
that will um ask that ask
kids to journal to write a journal about
the word
or write a blog so like
your development and stuff like that
right it's really important for the
thought process to write things down
because
you will forget if you don't but then i
if i do ask him to do that i will
ask him to write in a notebook uh but
i do ask them to use a computer if
they're looking for music or searching
for like a certain scene that we're you
know getting some inspiration but
as a preset we don't come in with a
computer to class
and i think that one of and again in
this decade that i've been working
you're right i think that you were a
transition age in which you guys had
the privilege of doing um you know
old school learning with a pen and a
paper
but i think today ninety percent of
of uh classes will be with the use of a
laptop
sure um which creates
a kind of disconnect you know there's a
little bit of an alien
like again if you are a people person
then it doesn't matter if you'll have a
hundred screens around you sure
to communicate right did i see a
difference in generations
as the years go by yes yes what
i feel like yeah i feel like
um first of all it makes me feel older
because it makes me feel so old because
i feel like
you know i see these generations passing
by and kids changing and
you're not comprehending like how kids
are evolving
and you're staying in this at the end of
the day i'm a 90s
high schooler you know like i was in
high school in the 90s we didn't have
computers we didn't have all these
things so
looking back it looks so completely
different but i think that
um so so
this creative outlet i think kids are
very creative i don't think
i don't think you can take creativity
out of a child that's in their dna
but um they take it out on the with
themselves
on their screen right and to shut down a
screen and
force a kid to look into each other's
eyes is one of the most awkward things
yeah yeah so awkward
and i mean i don't know if you're really
awkward for me today so
obviously but it is not obviously it
it's already awkward because you're a
teenager
i don't know if you remember uh we when
uh paulina sang
the winner takes it all and she had to
sing looking into maura's eyes
um and amit i mean it's not a ma
i mean i'm mars the brother yeah and uh
it was the hardest rehearsal yeah
it's a four-minute song and there's no
one on stage and there's a spotlight on
you and all you're doing is looking at
that person and
so it was very very it's awkward but
it's important to learn the skill
i learned so much about about humans and
interaction and relationships uh between
people through
through our through our plays and i have
to transition that because that that
is the most fascinating thing that i can
ask you about
the community and the family that you're
building through these productions
so you're doing a high school production
a middle school production
taking a group of you know 10 to 20
students
who have a lot of other stuff going on
they're not professional actors or
actresses or dancers or singers
they are happy-go-lucky kids and
some of them more nerdy some of them
more athletic and you're pretty much
saying within a few months we're going
to be putting up these in this amazing
production
talk walk me through this process what
happens from the audition
to the end result well i think that you
know one of them
one of them like the magic of theater if
we take out like the classes where
we look at the communication and speak
drama
the productions is you know tr i
always tell the kids try to visualize
the fact that you're taking
black little letters on a white piece of
paper
and you're giving it life okay at the
end after two months
it won't be a piece of paper with
writing on it it will have
you of you have built life and that's
and and for me that's theater you know
the expression of life you bring
you express relationships like you said
you express
uh what emotions are you express what
people are thinking you bring up uh you
you
embody a human being and
and i think that's the process that they
go through i am not a director that
i don't i don't really care so much
about
the position in which someone is
standing on stage
what angle they're standing at right but
what is it what do you mean to say what
do you want from your partner
you know when you're saying to someone i
love you what are you actually
saying to them you know what's your
subtext are you saying i need you don't
let me go i am vulnerable without you
are you saying um i i hate you
but i need you to be here to hear me or
you know what is it
what is it that you want from your
partner okay so
and thinking about like how acting is
reacting to one another so if i say
how are you michael i don't randomly
throw it out there there's an
expectation to hear an answer so if i
poke you in the eye
i expect you to shut your eye right
because that acting is reacting and
that's what acting is
so and you layer it up you know it's a
step-by-step
process and i think that once once the
kids understand that that's what they're
doing
that's when the magic comes because you
can dress your character up and you can
say okay my character is a unicorn and
i'm going to put a little horn over here
and you know yay but it doesn't mean
anything if if it doesn't have
the the inside is not filled up with
wants and needs and conflict
and um obstacles and dreams you know and
you're trying to imagine a life for that
person
the the key word that i'm hearing here
is awareness because i remember for me
spending those rehearsals and being on
stage you have to be so aware
of yourself your surrounding the
different things that are happening
the different changes that could take
place during a show and having to adapt
to them so
so you know one of the things that i
thought about this going going into
you know acting or being on the stage is
yeah okay so you memorize you rehearse a
hundred different times
lirania kobe might scream at you 99 of
those times until you get it right the
100th time
and not what to do about how to express
yourself yeah and then you just do it
and it's automatic but
what that won't be noticed in the five
runs of mamma mia or legally blonde or
you can't take it with you
every time it's different the audience
is different the the people are bringing
in their own life onto the stage
and i think one of the beautiful things
of having experienced a non-professional
production was that we it was very hard
at least for me and from some of my
friends to distinguish
our personal life from the character
and the show that we're doing and i
remember especially you know during
legally blonde
there was a lot of like drama like high
school drama going around and you saw
how every show
had a different feeling had a different
a communication style on and off the
stage
and it made me much more aware of people
and emotions
and i and hope and i think it also
taught me more empathy so
so i think that i got so much more than
just
you know taking black words and putting
them on on the stage
it meant a lot a lot to me so first of
all i'm really really
it makes me very emotional and excited
to hear that even
nine eight seven years after you've done
this production that you still carry
this experience with you and yes
absolutely agree with you that giving
life to a character is complete like a
a complete exercise in empathy and
um and yes theater is live
it's alive and it you know and this is
what people say you know
they say after seeing a broadway show
how can these people be doing this 700
times
um it's it changes even if it's
minuscule and you as an audience member
will not see the difference
it's it's it's the way you come you know
you might have won the lottery that
morning
or your pet might have died and you're
still
bringing in this character but and
there's a different you may sing a happy
song but there's a different depth to it
you know and
uh yeah and and it's live and it's on
you and you're reacting to an audience i
mean i don't mean
you know there are um there are
performances in which the audience
and especially in a school when you have
it's an international school and you
might
have uh the parents come and they're 90
of them don't speak english as a first
language
and they're not laughing at the jokes
that you thought
are oh my god they're so obvious out
there and you're
and but so you're dealing with
as an as an actor you're having not only
a relationship with your co
co-actor but also a relationship with
the audience member
and or how it how uh like a burst of
laughter will
immediately ignite this energy boost of
energy for the rest of the
performance and um but and i think also
like that is like
that's the magic of performance you know
and for me
being able to teach kids uh and having
them experience that
is what is worth everything everything
everything you know like
that was my next question because you
can you know with your experience uh
there's so many opportunities of of
places where you can be and things you
can do
in the drama and theater world you chose
to be an educator and spend
much of your time working with kids
who've never sung
danced spoken on stage help overcome
speaking public speaking fears helping
overcome you know social anxiety and and
teaching them empathy
and in scenarios that in circumstances
that they might not have otherwise
it sounds it sounds great but it's very
hard work why
why did you choose to do that hard work
instead of going and having fun at
habima in safta
or any other theater well first of all
to be fair
uh a professional the professional
acting world isn't
isn't easy like anything that is
professional you know like uh
i i assume that starting startups
looks like fun but it's also a lot of
work 99
fail yeah yeah and uh you hear many no's
next to these
wonderful yeses that you might hear in
the news
but i think that for me the transition
from
uh the professional life of an actor
director
to teaching was this
you know i was thinking when we talked
about you know having this interview or
this conversation i was thinking my gosh
you know like um
what like it helped me reach respect on
myself a little bit
and i remember acting school and acting
school for me
was a greenhouse of creativity was
i could fail miserably you know you
don't even understand how many times
i threw myself out there and did the
most ridiculous things
because i could you know because i had
the ability to try
and fail and i could wake up the next
morning and try again
okay and that was magical for me but
when i went out from acting school into
the professional acting world
i didn't have that anymore i didn't have
that because
you go to a casting director and they're
looking at you and
you know what do you sell you know who
what what kind of
what what character are you they don't
want to deal with
you know your creative outlets and they
don't have time it's a business you know
um but
and then i love that sentence they don't
they don't they don't want to deal with
your creative outlets
it's kind of true again
meryl streep and she's a one in a
generation you know like she can do
anything she can or uh do judy dench or
you know like there are a number of
privileged you know god gifted human
being
that can be doing that but most of us no
you know like you can
i'm not going to name our famous actors
but you know you can imagine in your
mind that
you see it one movie you see 10 movies
with the same actor
at the end of the day they're the same
people you know totally
but then and then i started teaching you
know like doing activities
and and i found that creative outlet
again you know for me like that's
such a key word you know i found the joy
of letting my students you know
let them fail and say to them it's okay
to try and fail fabulously
you know there's no other there's no
other places where you can do that
i mean even in sports in practices
you're practicing with the team
and you know even if your coach says
yeah i try something phil miserably
it's not the same it's so competitive
and you're always judged
on stage you're not being judged well
you know it's like
again like it really i think depends on
the experience that you have but i mean
i do
write i it's i think one of my my jobs
as a teacher as an
educator is is to create
a um a safe zone where you're coming to
the theater
and yes no one will judge you because
like you
your friend danny and johnny will fail
maybe not today but tomorrow and it's
okay because
you will through you you will all excel
at some point and you will all fail at
some point
and it's wonderful because you tried
things out that you didn't know you had
in you
maybe an accent maybe a certain walk
maybe you have you know a mimic in the
face and
and um and at the end of it
you found how much gratifying
you know gratifying it was for them to
be able to find that little something in
them
that they didn't know what they had
there so what better job in
life is to work with children and being
able to see them
find themselves you know iran incredible
i had
a horrible fear of dancing my whole life
and i'll never forget the day you come
and say well michael you know the roll
of pepper comes with a minute
solo dancing on stage i'm like what do
you mean what what's that
and they took time and it took tries and
i made a fool of myself quite a few
times
and probably up until the also in the
show itself but looking back
every now and then i i find that clip on
youtube and it's like
like wow like i remember how scared i
was of dancing and here i'm on stage
still horribly dancing almost falling
off the stage but i'm having so much fun
with so much confidence and it's all
thanks to you i mean you gave me that
confidence
you know i think it's i first of all
thank you so much but i do have to say
to you that i remember you
um you know i i can't be in the head of
a teenager
because i was you know like it's been a
while
but you might have like in your head you
might have felt this like
oh my god what does she want from me but
you never you never
showed that you know you and again like
that's another lesson in theater an
improv
like classic improvisation yes and
yes and yes and yes and and you did
and i was able to to give you a i could
have canceled the solo
we had live music we could have
cancelled the flow but you said yes
and i'll yeah i'll jump from the bar yes
and and so you gave me i was so
dangerously wrong i could have broken an
ankle looking back
i was young and foolish back then
uh uh but i i believed in you guys and i
think that i think that
i think that you felt comfortable very
because you felt that i believed in you
and then i think that this it's a it has
to go both ways you know you've got to
trust your director
it's true i get exasperated and i may
scream and i may yell
and you know like blow my my brain i'm
not gonna lie
i'm a very emotional director um
because i'm a perfectionist and i expect
you know the best
for myself so i expect the best for my
kids definitely
um but i think i do try to
create a trust a trusting relationship
in which the actor
can knows that he's in safe hands you
know
i love him and i said i always say to
the kids i
will you know i will not sleep for two
months
yeah to make sure that when you guys go
on stage you are proud of what you do
you will not go on stage
feeling ashamed we're not doing a play
just to do a play because it says in the
calendar play in march we're doing a
play
because we are going to be remembering
this day forever
and thinking on you know our past days
what a wonderful experience this was you
know i love it leron this is this is so
this is so fantastic and it's impossible
to capture in 20 minutes
the inspiration that you gave me and so
many others over so many years and i
can't believe
you're finishing your 10th year and i
started my 10th year finished my 9th
oh it's just as crazy i can't because i
remember when you came and i remember
when
every like it was all like a big startup
in school like nobody real nobody knew
what's happening no none of us knew
what's happening uh incredible
iran before we leave and the hardest
question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or the
or that any actor that you've worked
with would describe you as
i think that the first um word
to mind would be creative definitely
the other thing would be uh
insightful i have they're able to be
insightful and i think i don't know if a
a co-actor but a student
i would think i am young or youthful
you know like that would be also
something that uh
i am i can be relatable so maybe
relatable so 100 yes these are the three
things
but i mean there's more and i don't know
not everything is good
a hundred percent only one i know i'll
add a fourth word i'll say educator
mainly because
we didn't i didn't take a single class
with you and there's no record of
ais or my academic record that will show
any connection between the two of us yet
looking back at my uh 12 years of
education if i
had to choose a few things that really
shaped
who i am as a thinker and as a as a
human being i definitely think that our
work together was a
major major part of it if not the
biggest part of it and here i am you
know i'm an engineer i'm in
ai but but i'm looking back at this
experience as one of the most monumental
in my life
and thank you and so just know of the
impact that you're
and and i'm taking this also as an
impact that drama teachers and theater
and
the directors and choreographers have
all over the world on students
and and and while things are moving
online i hope that we are able to retain
this thing but yeah thank you so much
thank you for being on the show
thank you so much michael i'm so proud
of the man that you've become
thank you thank you thank you
you